all right here's our P he is a former
foreign
policy oh thank
you foreign policy advisor to Senator
Bernie Sanders who is now the Executive
Vice President of the center for inter
International policy Matt DUS welcome to
the show
Matt and he's a columnist for tablet
magazine and author of Secret City the
hidden history of gay Washington James
kek is back with us
Jamie um so
um difficult week difficult to talk
about it but we must um as often is the
case this show is at variance with some
of the conventional wisdom and what we
see on the media a lot U mostly what I
saw this week was one a shocking amount
of support like even at the moment of
the Rampage or right after when they're
still counting the bodies that was
shocking to me uh but even at its best I
feel feel like most of the people who
you would read in the
media the attitude is sort of like well
you know this is very complicated I
don't really study it I don't really
know the facts so I'm just going to go
with a kind of they're both guilty
equally and a moral equivalency which I
would like to take issue with tonight I
think the Israelis have always had the
moral High Ground And I think they still
do but we'll get to
that
but
there I'd also like to say to my friends
in Israel there's a Siege that's now
been going on for six days no
food no water no medicine is getting in
the head of the Red Cross in the mid
East said today this is not acceptable
we need a safe humanitarian space I
agree you know don't lose the moral High
Ground I mean I hate the word
proportionate when it comes to killing
it's it's horrible but it's sort of like
the best we can do what does that mean
proportionate I I I just don't know I
don't know but if if Israel is going to
kill babies now for the next I don't
know how long they're just the world
world just going to be able to say you
just do it in a different way I'm just
saying to Israel don't don't do what we
did after
9/11 don't do a Vietnam don't do in
Afghanistan of course you should
retaliate of course you have every right
but this could go to a place that was is
very bad for Israel I think your
reference to 911 is apt because we are
in a moment right now of grief and
Trauma um Israelis absolutely um and
that's not a moment to make great policy
and I say that with great respect um
they clearly have to respond they have
every right to respond the Israeli
government has every right and
responsibility to defend its people what
we saw uh last weekend was absolutely
shocking and barbaric um there are no no
two sides to that um we have to condemn
that unequivocally there is no
justification
I I will say
that that does that does not mean we
can't have a conversation about the
deeper context year we have to have that
conversation that does not justify in
any way what happened you said there's a
Siege on Gaza that's right there has
also been a blockade uh since 2007 um
that is part of this context again not a
justification never a justification um
well a blockade from a land they gave
back yeah they back Gaza is they
withdrew their forces and settlements
from within Gaza okay but the reason
there's a blockade is to stop like
this from happening no I with that's the
whole
point they gave it back they said you
know what make your life your own this
conflict right now could end right this
second if Hamas were to put down its
weapons and surrender unconditionally I
know it would never happen but that's
but that's the reality and this has
always been the it's always been the
reality of this conflict if the Arabs
were to put down their weapons and this
goes back to the 1930s before the
creation of the state of Israel if the
Arabs put down their weapons there would
be peace if the Jews put down their
weapons there'd be no more Jews in the
Middle East yeah well that's and that's
the thing I want to I want to get I
mentioned this about I it bothers me the
moral equivalency that goes on in the
American Media I don't think Israelis
would ever purposely kill babies I think
they have killed babies that's
collateral damage which is another
horrible thing but that's part of War I
think I think that there's a very big
difference between rejoicing when you
kill civilians and the Israelis regret
when they kill civilians I'm not going
to take issue with that but let me let
me add one thing about the context to it
um it it is very important to understand
that the Israeli strategy up until last
weekend had been to bolster hamas's
control of Gaza there was a report that
came out of Benjamin Netanyahu talking
to a meeting of the lud party in 2019
saying and I quote our strategy anyone
who wants to prevent the creation of a
Palestinian state has to bolster Hamas
and give them money this is how we keep
the Palestinians divided and therefore
it will never be a Palestinian state
this is not someone who is interested in
peace with the Palestinians I'm sorry
and this this policy goes back to the 19
that's coming after 75 years of being
attacked the question here so it's not
coming in a vacuum I I I totally agree I
would say there is again part of the
challenge of talking about this issue
and I again I just want to say I
appreciate being here to talk about this
and I you know to have a really
respectful discussion here because I'll
just say again what happened last
weekend is is beyond shocking but I
think we can disagree about the history
we can disagree about who did what and
who's to blame at different times but
ultimately these two people are going to
have to share this land and the question
is how we get to that point right and we
will talk about the history I just want
to finish with the values first because
it's just amazing to me that the
American left so much of it throws their
lot in with people whose
values I I hope they don't share but
let's go through them because values and
Customs make a difference okay and the
people of Gaza by the way if the
Israelis did get rid of Hamas they'd be
doing a giant favor to the people of
Gaza who hate Hamas too but uh let's
just go through the
lists because the Israelis rep look like
us in most ways values wise maybe we're
not doing it the right way I don't know
religious tolerance that doesn't exist
in Gaza you're either a Muslim or an
Infidel and you better be a Muslim
female Freedom free and fair
elections Free
Speech gay rights I see these queers for
Palestine did you hear their sister
organization blacks for the
[Laughter]
KKK it's like by the way I'm I'm a I'm a
gay man I've lived in Berlin this is a
level of masochism that even I cannot
comprehend
right I
mean
you know what I'm going to uh uh can I
just finish my list of pedophilia I'll
put that under don't
ask child brides and so forth equality
of the Sexes I'll categorize that under
don't make me
laugh the the fact that you know these
people think that this is where they
should
be aligned with that these are the
values that you support I think this
this past week has been a real important
moment for a moral Reckoning on the
American left because there is a small
and I'm going to emphasize that a very
small but growing in Extremely Loud
faction on the American left that has
revealed itself I don't know how small
anymore okay well I don't it was all
over it was well we just had a
conversation about the algorithm right
and I think you have a few groups you
have some college groups you have some
activist groups it's College okay and
and again I you know having gone to
college I I thank God every day that
social media didn't exist uh when I was
there
um but I will just say you know my
friend my friend uh Dan drar from tup
University wrote you know I think
recently um he just posted it again he's
like college is where you go to say
stupid things that is not to defend what
they said I think these things were
gross and Reckless and I'll note that a
number of groups that have signed some
of these statements have been pulling
themselves off it I don't want to
overrepresent this as part of the
political left I absolutely accept a
responsibility as someone who is on the
left and wants to build a responsible
and effective left of calling this out
um but I don't think we should over
represent these feelings on the left
because they are not a majority they are
not close to a majority I think we need
I hope
that they're a lot bigger than they used
to be well we hear a lot more about them
because as as you heard there there is
an interest in in promoting this I think
we need to shut down Harvard University
until we figure out what the hell is
going
on you're saying they're not sending us
they're not sending us their best
they're not sending us
I do I do want to say something pretty
pretty serious here though well I will
maintain and agree with with James here
that this is a small minority um I have
heard from colleagues Jewish colleagues
on the left and my friend Michelle
Goldberg wrote a piece in the New York
Times my friend Josh leafer wrote a
peace in descent and I've been struck by
personal conversations here too from
Jewish colleagues uh on the left who I
consider allies very close friends and
they have been shocked and I take that
very very seriously because again as
someone who wants to build a serious and
effective left if Jews do not feel that
the left is a home for them we will not
have a serious and effective
left